and on the mound for your tigers today
you've got jose urania with that real
good two-seam fastball running it down
and away to the left-handers down and
into the righties
there's a ground ball base hit for both
3-2 fastball they took it right back up
the middle and he starts his night with
a one-on-one single
slider off the play throw to second base
hits bull
right in the ribs
he's going to third
out
throw him out
don't get greedy
[Applause]
alec manoa who takes his five and two
three eighteen record
they throw him a change happening it's a
pop-up oh bushette is going to give way
to curiel the left fielder three up
three down for manoa
another ground ball that'll get past the
short stop in the left
[Applause]
arena nice play oh and he'd throw him
out no problem
got him went to a slider and strikes him
up first strike out of the game for
manoa and he strikes out his boy who
would idle with a nasty slider they're
two wins away from 64 right now there's
a good running fastball for strike three
manoa hits that outside corner i'm not
striking out the side in a second he
gets cabrera candelario and haas in
order
hoping to get at least three out of them
we'll see wave and a miss by smith
second strikeout of the night for jose
arena two-way
the 3-2 pitch
this one will get through the left side
as he hits it into the left field mark
as a simian
there goes simeon
lying to left center badoo got a good
jump and he retires boba sheds
there's that running fastball that's
been money for him three straight called
strikeouts four in a row for manoa now
you've set him up for your best pitch
that's what pitching is all about manoa
is going to argue that he stuck his knee
out in front and
he is upset by the bat at the fact that
he moved his knee in there and he's
going to argue with the home plate
umpire
adam beck
well i think he has
an argument
you have to make some kind of in the
umpires judgment a way to get out of
the way
you have to make some kind of move out
of the way and i think that's what alec
is saying hey he stuck his knee out
there and took the hit
rips one of left
base hit for derek hill
ground ball ball will step on second for
one back to first there's the ground
ball that manoa is looking for
alex flang is in in a wall side windows
pitching change it's his 20-second
appearance seemo
he struck him out
where he slaps it through the left side
for a base hit another very good at-bat
for corey dickerson he gets himself a
two-out single
here's the payoff
wave and a miss and lang strikes out
valera to end the inning he had 17 total
innings of professional
experience there's a hot shot loved by
valera what a nice play
his first chance since coming into the
game taking over for espana he takes a
hit away from scope
got him this time he strikes him out on
a fastball five strikeouts for vanilla
for the blue jays center fielder and he
looks at strike three to start the fifth
you still bitter about that right
slightly the 3-2 struck him out
back-to-back punch-outs for tyler
alexander here in the fifth three four
sometimes five years to learn that
and there's another terrific fastball
and again that's not being cocky that's
just being confident that you know they
knew they were good and they're like let
me show you
this one is sinking in a nice catch by
curiel in left field that sinking liner
he makes a sliding catching pass
hernandez getting the start of this game
off as kirk moved into the cleanup spot
swinging and drive left field get up
ball get out of here and gone
alejandro kirk with his fourth home run
has broken the scoreless tie he got a
high cutter and turned on it boy that's
how you hit like a number four hitter
nobody on base go ahead and drive
yourself in he's got some power with
that swing that if he gets the ball
elevated in like that and times it up he
can hit it as far as anybody
inside he will take ball four
one one pitch ripped into left field for
another base hit curios perfect on the
night two hits and a walk been on base
all three times
down the right field line grossman's got
it in fair territory and alexander
retires the pinch hitter tay oscar
hernandez
it's this ball in the air to shallow
center field castro is out second
baseman misplayed it looked like he
never saw the 2-2
to left field badou charging and diving
and making the grab what were we just
talking about energy
athleticism
hunger the runner is second base
robuschette the batter
there's a base hit into right field
which is going to come around to score
and boba shed picks up an rbi a big rbi
for the blue jays as they have made it a
two-nothing game for beau his 79th ruby
of the season
the payoff to scope
grounded right side base hit just the
second hit of the night for the tigers
and the first since derrick hill's
single in the third
the 2-1 to right center field get down
and it does
back-to-back hits for the tigers to
kick-start the seventh for miguel
cabrera
got him
came back with a fastball and strikes
him out
one out for jamer candelario candelario
has struck out twice tonight
the one rip to right center scope will
get waved home
he will score grossman to third
candelario comes through and gets the
tigers on the board
trevor richards trevor that's what he
has done in his 38 games with tampa
milwaukee and the blue jays this season
runners at the corners only one out eric
haas 2-2 to haas
chopper to short
the shed had to back up haas down the
line they didn't get him we're tied at
two
hit against the shift a couple of bats
ago
and there's another base hit just put
the bat on the ball they keep pitching
him away and it keeps slapping it the
other way that's his second hit of the
night
he struck him out
[Applause]
he got him 96 mile an hour fastball two
away
he walks willy castro to start the
eighth
and he's called out on strikes that
fastball at the knees he can't get the
bunt down and soria strikes him up
and sorya strikes him out
there's a base hit gotta buy the
shortstop into the final lead-off single
for kevin smith see if he challenges
popped it up
left side harold castro
is under it
got him gregory soto up to the challenge
right
field base hit
cabrera now 40 hits shy of 3 000
pinch runner perhaps yep it'll be daz
cameron
get in the air popped up
curiel drifts into foul ground he makes
a catch and we're gonna go to the tent
you see kyle funkhouser on a wall side
windows pitching change he will get the
10th
it's going to be interesting to see how
they play cory dickerson
flares this one to left field this is
going to be trouble it'll drop in front
of badou
vlady's coming around third and he's
gonna be safe
bloody guerrero almost fell down coming
around third but he got a good read saw
that badou wasn't going to catch it and
the blue jays have the lead zach short
who is pinch running for eric haas who
made the last out
bouncing bajas breaks for third they got
a shot at him and he's an easy out boy
he hesitated and anytime you do that you
just got to shut it down
strike three and that's the ball game
romano
strikes him out on a hard fastball up in
the zone and the blue jays win an extra
inning game for just the third time this
season